ايضا في الجانب السوري بالمتطوع في الدفاع
المدني السوري ندى الراشد ندى مرحبا بك
معنا
الدفاع المدني السوري وجه مناشدات بضروره
التحرك العاجل في الاستجابه لهذه
الكارثه ما الذي وصلكم حتى الان
اول شيء حابه احكي انه عزائنا لاهالي
الشهداء او نامل منها الله انه نقدر ننقذ
اكبر عدد من الموجودين تحت الضحايا
حاليا هي كارثه حقيقيه يعيشها شمال غرب
سوريا مئات العائلات تحت الانقاذ الاف
الضحايا والمصابين والوضع ماساوي جميع فرق
الدفاع المدني مستنفره بشكل كامل
وجهنا استغاثات للمنظمات المحليه والدوليه
المساعدات عم تكون بالاستجابه من كل
الجهات الموجوده في شمال غرب سوريا حتى من
قبل المدنيين ولكن هذا لا يكفي الكارت
كبير وحجم الدمار كثير كبير نحن بحاجه الى
عتاد نحن بحاجه الى اليات ثقيله ناشدنا
الدول بالمساعدات وارسال العتاد والاليات
الثقيله نحن فرقنا اليوم الثاني على
التوالي ما زالت
مره بعملها عشرات المدنيين يبحثون عن
اقاربهم تحت الانقاذ صيغات الناس اللي
موجوده تحت الانقاذ ونحن عم نسمع صوتهم
وصل عدد الضحايا اليوم
حاله وفاه ولكن عدد بشكل متزايد وبسبب
وجود الاف العيال اللي موجوده تحريض اريد
ان اعود معك الى نقطه الحاجات التي
تطلبونها في هذه الايام وهي ايام جد حاسمه
في عمليه الانقاذ وانتشال
العالقين هم احياء يعني انتم بحاجه الى
معدات ثقيله وادوات واليات اذا لعمليات
الانتشال هل وصلت اي منها خلال هذه
المناشدات خلال الساعات الماضيه ام لم تصل
من الدول ما وصلت ولكن وصلت استجابات من
قبل المدنيين لان اللي عندهم حالات اللي
عندهم معدات ثقيله فوجهوها لعنا ونحن وجه
لفارقه الدفاع المدني نحن عم نشتغل فيها
ولكن كمان في عنا نقص بالفيول نحنا يعني
شو بدي اقول لك عدد الاليات ما ما بتكفي
للي كانت الموجوده نحن فيها ووقود لتشغيل
ايضا هذه الاليات اذا لديكم نقص ايضا
بالوقود
لم يدخل المزيد من الوقود خلال هذه
الساعات التي لحقت
بحدوث الزلزال
حاليا لحد الان ما تم يعني ما وصلتنا
اضافه بالاليات او الفيول من اي دوله
المساعدات عم تكون من قبل المدنيين اللي
موجودين بشمال ضرب سوريا بما توفر فيها
تلك المنطقه وليست عمليه يعني زياده في
عمليه ادخال
المواد اللازمه والوقود خلال هذه الفتره
حتى حتى المدنيين يعني حتى الوضع الماساوي
للمدنيين بسبب
الهزاز الارتداديه الوضع الوضع الطقس
السيء اللي موجود هون اكثريه الناس كانت
موجوده يعني بالشوارع وجهت الدفاع المدني
لجميع المنظمات
للجهات المعنيه الموجوده
بمساعده الناس اللي موجوده ضمن الموجوده
في الشوارع فتنفتح بعض المدارس وبعض
المساجد وبعض مراكز الايواء في سرمدا في
ادلب في
معرض مصريا في كل
لاستقبال هذول الناس طيب ندى اذا ما
انتقلنا الى القطاع الصحي وهو قطاع جد
حيوي خلال هذه الكارثه وعملوا مهم جدا من
اجل يعني
تكمله عمليات الانقاذ كيف يبدو وضعه هل من
مساعدات وصلت لهذا القطاع
هلا القطاع الصحي نحن كفرق دفاع مدني في
عنا كمان
استجابه اسعافات اوليه فنحن فرقنا وجهت
وجهت لمكان الحادثه
سواء فرق النساء او فرق الشباب الاسعاف
الاسعافات الاوليه لتقديم الاسعافات
الاوليه مع السيارات اسعاف مجهزه
فتم
يعني وحتى تم فتح مراكزنا جميع النسائيه
لاستقبال الحالات الطبيه بالاضافه الى
تحويل الحالات
الطبيه للمشاكل الموجوده
باماكن الحادثه او الاماكن اللي بعيده عن
الحادثه الوضع الطبي اكيد في حاجه الى
مساعدات طبيه
خارجي لانه الوضع والعدد الوفيات وعدد
الاصابات كثير كبير
فجباره بده يكون لازم يكون في مساعدات
لقطاعات طبيه المتطوعه في الدفاع المدني
الس ندى الراشد نتمنى ان تصل رسالتكم الى
كل الدول والجهات التي من المفترض ان
تتجاوب مع هذه المناشدات في الدفاع المدني
السوري شكرا لك حدثتنا من ادلب